so what I want to talk about tonight
what Calvin asked me to talk about so if
it's a bad idea it's his fault was a
little bit about how Python fits in the
space for beginners now I know a lot of
you are not beginners especially if
you're looking for work maybe it's
better not to be a beginner at that
point but even if you're not a beginner
is there anybody who is who's brave
enough to say so you're just learning
Python yes you and me dude okay
excellent great this is for you the rest
ease people can hang out but actually
this would be useful for all of us too
because I don't know about you but as
I've not gotten smarter but I've gotten
grayer
and so people expect me to be able to
help them learn how to do things and as
you become a senior dev you're always
ending up having to teach people am i
right most of us are not good at that
I'm just saying and you know I love to
go on the learning program forums and
Reddit and so on and it's comedy gold so
what are we gonna talk about we'll see
how you can think like a programmer even
if you're not sure you can and how does
each beginners with my fun you like that
look at that whoo that's fun
alright so you don't need to know much
more about me except here's my favorite
thing that Calvin didn't know I used to
be a special ed teacher yeah I know it
was actually severe disabilities in
North Central High School that was the
best best preparation for being a
computer science teacher I could have
ever had it really was and I'm not being
facetious here I mean some of my
students are here they're like yeah
you're true yeah because I learned how
to teach I really learned a lot about
teaching and I'm still learning about
teaching 20-some years in I'm learning a
ton about teaching I actually I think
programming is hard do you agree see
this was the interactive part yes okay
programming is every bit as hard as most
people think it is I think teaching is
harder I honestly do I think that's the
more valuable more difficult more rare
skill which is funny because there's a
lot of people with the title
who don't have the skill so yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know all that stuff goofy
dude that's the most important one
all right so how smart are they oh I
didn't do it
I didn't do it Nick can you run outside
I need a rock huh sure will work I'll
use my shoe that's the scary thing they
knew where I was going with this okay
who's got a good gaming rig okay yeah
what you got tell us your specs it
doesn't matter excellent that's a good
machine good machine okay normally I
have a rock but I'll just use the shoe
how smart are they you thought I was
talking about the students didn't you no
I was talking about how smart are the
computers there's that gaming computer
and there's my shoe which one's smarter
it's a tie it's a tie and if you don't
get that we're done that's the most
important thing about learning how to be
a programmer don't you agree now I'm
gonna have to take the other one off for
a walk in circles all right so how smart
are they not the people that's never the
problem the people who I teach usually
are super super they're really really
clever and bright and wonderful that's
never the problem I've not encountered
anybody yet who couldn't learn to
program if they wanted to I've met
several who don't want to but how smart
are they I'm not talking about the
people I'm talking about the computer
see the hard part about writing a
computer program isn't trying to be as
smart as the computer it's trying to
learn how to be as mind-numbingly stupid
as a computer that's the hard part and
until you can understand that you'll
never really be able to write programs
do I get an amen yeah yeah all right so
learning to program is hard if you're
just doing it now do you agree with me
it's hard and in fact I'm still learning
to program my bananas for 30 years I'm
still learning I'll let you know when I
figure it out I still feel like an idiot
all the time am I the only one all the
time I like walk out of my office is
like why do people pay to read my books
people are actually paying to see my
class if I can't even get this stupid
thing to work her my wife is like get
back in there and get it working she is
loving she is awesome learning to
program it's hard why well program feels
different than other skills doesn't it
especially to a beginner yeah I'm good
at cars but I don't know this stuff
languages are scary right they see codes
code that sounds like it's a mystery
you're not supposed to know what it
works how it works
so the language is scary there's codes
you know you think the language is scary
the environments are scary we have these
IDs and you know I look at modern
development and then tell you 25
different steps you have to do before
you start opening your first program
that's insane absolutely insane well
first you have to develop your
environment especially JavaScript don't
get me going on that environment right
now
well the scariest thing let's be honest
sometimes it's us yeah because we love
to talk in jargon we love to talk about
all these things and we love all of our
really fancy ideas we love to show off
what we've learned and that might really
freak out a beginner yeah I'll show you
specific examples as we go don't you
worry most beginners have failed a lot
yeah and a lot of these are people who
are pretty smart they're not used to
failing
let's say these are people who did good
in school and they failed and then they
fail again and maybe they've gotten bad
advice and they follow that advice and
they fail and they feel stupid and why
would you go back someplace that makes
you feel stupid all the time that's a
good that's a good question it's super
easy to get bad advice isn't it well do
some of that and you know good
programmers are often good people but
not
always good teachers have you found that
to be true I've been one of those good
programmer not good teacher I've been a
bad programmer bad teacher too so this
stuff is hard I love this you know every
day I get to find out some bad beginner
advice here's things that I see on
forums and I've actually said probably
all of these just start with a simple
game you know you want to learn how to
program just start writing a simple
simple game like what kind of game Oh
something super easy like Tetris oh if
you've ever tried to read Tetris it's
not simple or you know just write
tic-tac-toe oh dear or this start with
C++ that's what they use in industry I
especially love that in the gaming
community you know you really need to
learn C++ because that's what they write
game engines in I'm like you are out of
your flippin mind
I love C++ but you're gonna begin with
that are you kidding me that's a super
bad idea because you know what's gonna
happen C++ awesome language you're gonna
feel stupid the first 15 seconds aren't
you if you've if you've tried to teach a
beginner in it actually C++ starts out
ok C and C out how hard could this be
yeah let's talk about memory allocation
huh yikes if you use Visual Basic you
don't have to code until the very end of
the project that's one of my favorites
you know my visual basic program is all
done except for the code I love that one
oh dear
yeah I used to teach that thank goodness
I'm done the best way to start is to
pick a problem you want to solve I like
this one I like this advice except it's
terrible because C you know I'd like to
solve world peace is that the first
problem I should try you know having
goals is good but if the goals lead to
inevitable failure and defeat maybe we
should pick a subset of saving the world
first you'll stay motivated if you work
on a real-world problem until you feel
like an idiot
and leave because here's the problem
with real world the real world is messy
isn't it and so I'm not so sure that we
always want to be focusing on real-world
problems to start here's things I wish
I'd been taught when I was a beginner
and I've only learned this after Bui
twenty thirty years of teaching this and
I'm still learning it programming is not
about languages this is the question I
hate the most on these forums right
reddit learn programming I'm there every
day to PI look for me what language
should I start with and I like I have to
stop because if I had quadruple size
caps-lock I would use it wrong question
that's stupid question
and here's the great thing you're gonna
get reams of advice about it all of it's
stupid programming isn't about languages
sure you're gonna pick one but the
language ultimately doesn't matter that
much
some would make you feel better earlier
some will make you feel stupid or
earlier public static void main string
args but the language doesn't really
matter programming was never about
languages you know here's my guys in the
back right in the first year of our
program I teach for programming
languages and you know the funny thing
that part's not the hard part that's
what they tell me am i lying now no ok
good ok good I'll still pay you um yeah
they think that's the hard part no the
hard part is we keep changing paradigms
the hard part as soon as we know one
language I start talking about something
deeper that we can learn another one
pythons not a good language to teach
direct memory management in for example
because it does it for us but if you're
a computer scientist you better know
what direct memory management is that's
when we're gonna work to in C and C++
make sense yeah mmm and free yeah you
guys don't know that your Python people
okay good
most people think that programming is
about memorizing I'll never learn all
those codes and I'm like yeah neither
will I I don't know what you're talking
about
I don't memorize syntax I couldn't
because I used too many languages you
know on a typical day I'm helping debug
code in six seven languages there's no
way I could memorize that okay this is a
good one most programming isn't about
math you know I'll never be a good
programmer I always hated bad first of
all you hated math class I'm not sure
you've met math secondly until you get
into data science gaming and a few other
specific areas you could do fine in
programming without using a lot of
calculus right who use calculus today
that's what I'm saying okay you did
you're very smart and there are places
we need it and certainly you know I use
linear algebra several times today
because I taught a game programming
class but I might not need it every day
you can get started without math and
here's the fun thing when you start
programming you're gonna realize the
kind of thinking you're doing is the
kind of thinking that math was trying to
teach you in the first place
so there you go programming languages I
love this one programming languages are
simpler than human languages I know this
because thirty years ago I tried to
learn Japanese and I completely failed
until very recently when I tried to
learn Spanish and now all the Japanese
is coming out what has this Tomodachi
son I'm the only person in the world
who's fluent it's Bethany's human
languages how much vocabulary do they
have lots how many words like a hundred
thousands okay how about the syntax
rules how complicated are they oh dear
Lord yeah you know my family is all
learning Spanish because my daughter's
going to school in Nicaragua and and you
know there's tenses I've never even
heard of you know past future wonderful
undescribed pretty pretty Cori sense I
don't know what it is but I don't even
understand it
computer languages how many words do
they typically have in the vocabulary
about a hundred how consistent is the
syntax painfully programming languages
are actually designed to be much more
sensible they're not as flexible poetry
and programming languages not quite as
successful except Perl of course it has
blessed kill and die those are functions
in Perl I could tell you my Perl joke
right so a thousand monkeys on
typewriters eventually one of them would
would type Shakespeare the others would
alright Perl code there's not many
places you can use Perl jokes that's
what I'm saying yeah programming really
isn't about the things most people think
it is here's another one programming you
know I can't type fast enough to be a
programmer I've heard that one actually
probably you should be typing slower
right how much of programming is typing
close to none of it close to none it's
really that the shoe again it's about
explaining things to the idiot computer
that's what programming is how we think
about it that way it's actually not
quite so frightening code isn't about
language here's what I'm beginning to
learn after teaching this for many many
years because I have taught beginning
programming pick a language Perl yes I
taught beginning programming in Perl and
basic and Pascal and Loco remember logo
no some of you don't and scratch
give me a language C C++ Java I've
taught him all its beginning languages
and they started to rub them together I
realize there are some common themes it
turns out when I'm teaching a beginner
how to go from not a programmer to a
programmer there's really about seven or
eight concepts depending on how you look
at them you get those and you're done
and those concepts are universal across
languages that's pretty beautiful isn't
it now
true if you know multiple languages you
know this to be true right your first
language is hard your second language is
harder isn't it because you thought you
knew the truth
your third language it's like dude I'm
seeing similarities here by four or five
you know you're doing you're doing the
was it was it oh yeah you were saying
they asked me to do a project Empire so
give me a weekend yeah it gets that
point doesn't it because we see these
these consistencies coding is only about
eight main concepts I'll show you my
favorite few how's that they work in the
same way in every language when we're
trying to teach people how to code don't
teach them code teach them English or
teach them in English the secret isn't
code the secret is algorithms and data
that's really what we're here to teach
and of course let's pick a language that
makes that easy I nominate Python if it
chooses to run it's gonna win we write
out the concepts first and then we
convert to code later this is so key
when my students come in to me and
they're like ah I'm so messed up the
first thing they do is sit down and they
open up their computer and what do I do
I shut it on their fingers why if you're
lost in coding it's probably because you
shouldn't be coding yet it's almost
always the case you write out the
concepts first and convert to code in
fact I will grade your paper if you wear
the beautiful algorithm and not a line
of code you'll still probably pass
doesn't happen often because if they
write the algorithm well the code comes
if you turn in beautiful code that runs
great without any comments in it I give
it back that's how important this is
after midterm anyway so most beginners
this is so amazing when you when you if
you are a beginner and I still am you
get to this point where you think you
don't understand how to write the code I
can't tell you how many times people say
I know what I'm doing I just don't know
which code to write
no no almost every time somebody says I
just don't know how to write it no
that's not the problem the real problem
is they don't understand the problem
they're trying to solve
they're jumping straight to coding
without understanding algorithms and I
get that
cuz coding is cool right you look like a
hacker I showed my son hacker typer you
know that site hacker typer calm oh you
need this hacker typer calm all you have
to do is bang on the keyboard furiously
and it looks like you're writing C code
and if you hit the right control
sequence it says like you're in NATO or
whatever yeah it's awesome
because that's what all of the students
think they're gonna learn how to do
anyway yeah and now you're all going
there I love it the real problem is that
beginners don't always understand the
problem they're trying to solve they try
to figure out how to do it before they
try to figure out what to do and really
experience people like us we do that too
don't we every day every day all right
here's one of my favorite ideas and then
we'll actually dig in and do some sound
good
comments are could wait alright so we
all know what comments are for comments
are there to explain code to other
programmers you agree sure sure
which explains why we never write them
doesn't it because if the comments are
there first of all it's their own dang
fault if they can't understand my code
secondly I don't want to explain what it
does until I'm sure I know and that may
never happen
well painful painful little giggles
there yeah cuz this is true right we're
all here and you know I gotta hit this
thing delivered man it's deadline I'll
do my best to get the comments in at the
last step but I gotta get it working
before I can worry about that yeah so
comments are there to explain the code
to other programmers or better yet
yourself because a week later you're
like crud what does this do no no no
I finally learned the truth comments are
not there to explain the code to
programmers code is there to explain the
comments to the computer that's profound
but that is that's all I got good night
I'll see ya code is there to explain
comments to the computer at least for
beginners but again I still consider
myself a beginner it writes your
algorithm first you got that algorithm
first working it's beautiful and then
how do you know it's done it's like a
turkey right the little thing pops out
no how do you know that an algorithm is
done you look at every line and at this
point maybe you even decided what
language you're gonna use and you say I
can do that I could do that I could do
that look better look that one up break
it up into smaller things I could do it
I could do it I could do it I can do it
at that point now we can start thinking
about code that sounds really meaning
doesn't it my students think so too
until they do well and they all learn
more than me so now they don't think
it's so bad this is important idea all
right so let's go into I said there were
only seven or eight main concepts let's
do our favor first four how's that No
okay it's been nice seeing you guys
here's the way I like to think about it
because really algorithms you can say
that and people like ya but let me show
you exactly how we like to think about
these I actually have one chart that
I'll make and it was uglier than the
slide show so you know if you want it
I'll give it to you but I have one chart
and I say you understand this it's an
HTML table
it's that ugly you understand this
you've got programming oh you want to do
it in Java one second change it all okay
great I changed one column so I just
rebuild that table for every language we
teach it but here's the ideas now the
first idea is about variables right
variables about data so those of you who
are really beginners today's our moment
if you're not a beginner garden oh
that's right but someday you're going to
teach it to someone okay
and the real issue isn't just a variable
okay it's a place of memory to hold data
great we know that but here's the
interesting thing about this approach to
learning is that I say first thing you
need to know is there is such a concept
as make a new variable and when I'm
running an algorithm this is one of the
things I can pick what am I going to do
I'm gonna make a variable so that's on
your drop-down list of things you can do
make sense there's only about eight or
nine of these really but when you say
that as soon as you say I'm gonna make a
new variable some questions should pop
in your mind oh dear hey there's some
HTML code why did that test die alright
so some questions should pop into your
mind or it doesn't matter what language
you're in no same questions anytime we
make a variable I guarantee you're gonna
need to know what's its name
what's its type what sort of data does
it hold those of us who've been
programming for a while know that
computers are a little fussy about that
you know we have integers that don't
have decimal point stuff and we have
floating-point numbers that have that
and then we have strings which is the
much cooler way to say text and then
we've got other stuff too and it depends
on which language how fussy you are
about that sort of thing right if this
was a Java group they believe you of
strict rated types baby
we're Python we're like man it's all the
same but does it still matter what type
something is even if maybe our language
isn't too fussy about it we shall see
initial value what's its starting value
so would you agree whenever you make a
variable in any language you think of
these things there might be some others
like scope but I'm gonna save that for
function scope doesn't mean much if you
don't have functions yet so whenever I
make a variable that's what I think do
you agree okay here's where you say yes
yeah yes please go home okay good good
thank you so how do you write in out an
algorithm this is the part I'm proud of
okay that's not the part I'm proud of
when it works is the part
how do you write an algorithm here's the
beautiful thing you must write in
English no coding allowed unless of
course English isn't your favorite
language and Swahili whatever cool
awesome create whatever it is I don't
care but your sentence has to answer
those questions it has to answer the
question what's its name what's the
starting value and what's its type
that's your algorithm does that make
sense
so when we're teaching a beginner to
make a variable the first thing they
need to know is I need to make a
variable and then the second thing they
need to know is what questions should I
always answer when I make a variable
that makes sense and then when we do
that honestly that's all they need but
see if I could get away with it I
wouldn't even teach a language yet but
they don't believe it's real coding
unless they're typing somewhere so fine
we'll do it that's how we write this in
Python name gets an it Val type huh
you're on your own but that's how we do
it in Python so I can live with that can
you live with that yeah sure because
we're Python programmers so that's good
so that's one of our concepts here's
another concept I mean it seems trivial
doesn't it but it isn't it isn't output
right what's another thing I can do well
I can tell the users stuff I'm gonna
start here with the command line console
because life is easier there isn't it
we're in charge I mean in the GUI the
users in charge and who put them in
charge not me
but output is pretty easy there's only
one thing to worry about what message do
I want to send the user and of course
outputs usually text isn't it
yeah outputs text so that's pretty easy
and we could write an algorithm for an
output line to couldn't we don't worry
there's a quiz coming I'll put the text
message okay that was really easy yeah
your code
yay for Python 3 yeah
[Applause]
system dot out dot print line no no no
console.writeline no it's easy it's
pretty except I always yeah see I think
printer
what's aperture I don't know you know I
still mess up the parentheses for is
sometimes cuz I you did to seven for a
long time wrote a whole book into so the
parentheses sometimes throw me but I
could do this now how much are we
worried about the Python syntax have you
seen how much we've stressed about that
why not
because you all know it but why because
that's the part we can look up how do I
do it in this language that part Google
will help us with woman if you turn to
Google how what problem am I trying to
solve you're gonna get some very scary
results but if you know what you're
trying to do you know I'm trying to
output text you can say how do I put
text in Python three and the chance of
sorry you'll get something pretty close
to this yes so the coding part is the
easy part in algorithm part is the hard
part
alright so we're getting to the point
where we have enough of these tools we
can start to put together a real program
there's a you know input now input I
like talking about input because this is
the first one that really starts to talk
about the real complexity of coding
isn't it because see all of the other
things were atomic they could kind of
stand on their own but input is really
mean input has like dependencies doesn't
it I mean you think about it when I when
I input something here um tell me the
answer tell me the answer come on 42
that's a good one I like that
yeah I'm coveting that t-shirt it's not
fair for me to ask you the answer if I
didn't ask a question is it it's never
stopped me as a teacher but if I am
asking for an answer I should really
give you a question
so an input applies that there was some
question asked of the user it may be in
that statement as it is in Python it may
be another line it doesn't matter much
but somehow we're gonna ask the user a
question well okay now
throw me the ball come on throw me the
ball come on you guys can help throw me
the ball please yeah you have a ball
threat you know what I should have done
I should have put up my men I shouldn't
ask for somebody to throw something if
I'm not ready to catch it yeah input you
have to have a variable to answer to
hold the answer you have to have a
question that you asked them so the
crazy thing about input is it should
never be the first line of your
algorithm you see on his hand it doesn't
make sense because there's there's like
prerequisites so you need to either in
the input statement itself or in another
statement you need to ask a question and
you already need to have a variable in
place that can catch the answer well
that makes a lot of sense doesn't it and
what does that have to do with Python
syntax nothing that's a different
problem and an easier one isn't it
that's an easier problem okay so how
would we do an algorithm again anyone
you want any line of algorithm as long
as it answers those questions makes me
happy
ask the user a message and store the
answer in variable beautiful we good
with that you want to see code you've
seen the code but it's easy variable
gets input message yeah but you see the
point I'm trying to make when we
understand the concepts the code itself
becomes actually at some point and this
is why we don't always write comments
right at some point this is more clear
than that but not for a beginner not for
a beginner so a beginner has to do this
part for a while before they can jump
straight to the code does that make
sense because we've forgotten that
sometimes and to the beginners that
we're trying to help this looks like
arrogance it's not it's forgetfulness
but we can see there's not a cleaner way
to say that I really can't think of an
easier way to say that in any of the
languages I used thank you we don't but
we forget that it's not obvious to
beginners
okay that's enough we can read a program
can't we sure we could with just that
all right I'm not gonna actually make
you write it because I want to get to
some other stuff but here's the program
we would write now for real life I would
stop right here no more
we've learned plenty you can't make me
teach you another line of code because
we would stop we get out paper and
pencil and we would write some
algorithms together in groups not by
yourself if you're really confused find
somebody who's feeling very comfortable
and make them uncomfortable and we write
this out and if you turn on a computer I
will slap the slap it shut on your
fingers cuz I don't want computers right
now I want brains those are much better
computers anyway right and so we write
this no code that's really hard for
those of us who think in code isn't it
yes I sometimes do dream in code it's
terrifying especially when my dreams
involve memory leaks it's a bad bad
thing honey just turn on the vel grind
she's like what's up al grind never mind
never mind
algorithm only I'll go ahead and do it
for us there's my first try you see what
I did here no code create an integer
variable for X created an integer
variable for Y create an integer
variable for some did I answer those
questions yeah okay I ask the user X and
put the answer in X ask the user Y and
put the answer in Y put X plus y and
some tell the user the answer is som
this is awesome okay some of you know
there's a problem and some of you are
like seriously I could have just written
this right but you're not a beginner
anymore if you're a beginner you need to
write it this way first now here's the
beautiful thing about Pi a Python right
we're a half a step away from Python
because python is beautiful except for a
few warts come on name equals main
that's pretty stupid
I love Python but that's it's work come
on it's still there and the whole self
oh please if you're gonna require self
as a parameter then tell me the right
number of parameters when there's an
error in the function because my
beginners are freaking the heck out it
says it only has two parameters when
there's three basic but there's four
okay so first we just write this as
plain text paper-and-pencil is better
than uncut whiteboard is my favorite
lipstick on the mirror cool blood on the
wall don't do that but we come up with a
plan then we take the plan and now we
convert it to comments now you could put
it in your text editor which one I do
not care if you're spending a lot of
time stressing about it wrong one I'm
actually still a vim guy I'm that nerdy
I know but I'm not gonna impose that
okay second class I do but but in the
first class no no I'm not gonna make you
do that but I want your editor out of
the way I'm not a huge fan of syntax
highlighting that doesn't solve the real
problems does it or a code completion
and all that stuff that doesn't solve
the real problems that solves the easy
ones the real problem is how do you
think well and the cleaner your editor
is the easier we get there this is a
pretty good answer isn't it is it code
well technically we could put it in an
editor and it wouldn't crash um it's a
great algorithm okay at least it's a
good algorithm would you agree no no I'm
sad okay I like it
now the next step okay now we can put in
code and so every line and this again is
something that we love to teach our
beginners or I do everybody else hates
it and and that is okay now that you've
got those comments one line at a time
you look for that comment and you tell
me how to write it in code go crazy with
Google if you want do it of course I
taught this in China and they said
what's Google okay Baidu
good luck
that's tortoise about that man teaching
Java in China please teach advanced Java
in English you've got one month I got
there and realized they didn't know
basic Java or English and that was the
translator yeah it was crazy so now each
of these things I can say dude I can
write that I can make that and in fact
this is the first time that it even
matters what language were in you know
maybe I'll go to the Java users group
I'll just change this slide except you
know I can't make the comment about
public static void main string args
which is huh oh yeah it's it's coming
yeah I'll show it to you yeah I've got a
yo-yo don't you worry anyway so we can
take each one of these things and we can
convert it to code in that beautiful
isn't it beautiful yes that's beautiful
and then of course we could test it and
again I'm not too fussy if you don't
have a copy of Python on your own
machine right now that's not a big
barrier I love some of the online
environments Python anywhere love that
one in fact I've got at work running on
there so you don't have to install it on
your own machine if you don't want to no
good reason not to come on you're using
a bun to write you've already got it
[Music]
here I happen to have it running I think
and I warmed up pi okay so there's that
same thing I just copied and pasted
shall we run it oh I am all the Twitter
here we go okay come on give me some
code yes I don't know what that is but I
think it's funny
okay x 3 y 5 this is going swimmingly 35
oh dear
really should have tested this shouldn't
know I knew what was gonna happen see
look at my next slide
stop it stop it stop it stop it ok this
is where we all go wrong this is where
we all go wrong first of all the first
thing we do failure is a wonderful thing
if you don't like failure you're in the
wrong business because how often do we
have miserable crashes a day I'm in it I
mean it happens all the time right if
you can't be big about that then you're
in the wrong job I don't know what job
is good for you but this one is it
because it's gonna crash a lot but our
failures are opportunities for us to
grow and we have to have a good attitude
about that and you know what we should
teach debugging the very first moment
because there is no programming that
isn't debugging isn't it I mean how much
of programming is debugging and how much
of it is actual programming it's pretty
much all debugging isn't it begin
debugging now now here's where everybody
gets in trouble one thing we all like to
do especially those experienced people
as we jump right at what the answer is
right we start solving this sucker and
often because we have a lot of
experience we do it very well
it really pisses the students off when I
do that I don't even see it we're
walking in the hallway and I can tell
them what lines wrong and I'm usually
right that really pisses them off except
at least their coats working because
I've given this assignment for a few
times and I know exactly why it's acting
stupid
but did you tell it what to do
incorrectly that's what most beginners
think I must have typed the wrong code
because they still think that
programming is about writing codes
that's what they always assumed or did
you tell it to do the wrong thing okay
we can think about this example did we
tell it how to do it wrong or did we
tell it to do the wrong thing
yeah one of those we don't know that's a
beautiful answer we don't know I don't
know is the best answer any programmer
could give me because if you do know and
it's not right you don't know this is
one I hate I just have one simple
problem professor then why are you in my
office if it was simple you would have
solved it you've done something
boneheaded I know and I'll help you but
don't pretend it's simple so often we
think that we just did it wrong but what
happened is we did the wrong thing maybe
with a good conscience but beginners
almost always assume it's an
implementation problem when it's almost
always an algorithm problem is that the
case here almost it's an understanding
problem and that's ok that's ok that's
wonderful that's gonna happen every day
and you know what I could have prevented
that I could have taught you how to
convert to an int first right but I
don't want to because the beautiful
thing is embracing those isn't it
embracing the fact that when we learn
how to code we fail all the time and boy
do you wish you learn this slide a
hundred years ago I still don't know how
but I've been yeah Adi buggers are good
I like debuggers although you can depend
on them okay this is my mr. Miyagi ISM
of the day best way to debug code not
have bugs and as although it's facetious
is it true yeah the best way to debug
your code is to write code defensively
sub bugs don't creep in that's very hard
to do it takes a lot of experience
there's other things you can do though
bad implementation if I just did it
wrong I could Google that if Google's
not getting you the right answer you
probably don't have bad implementation
you probably have bad algorithms or a
bad understanding of the problem space
those are much harder to find in Google
aren't they
bad algorithms you can't look those up
there's probably
something you're not understanding does
that make sense something's not acting
like it like it's supposed to and that's
when a debugger the idle debugger is
good again I'm still a PDB kind of guy
I'm just that old school cuz man a
command-line dude I can do a lot but
there's something I'm not understanding
going super slo-mo look at that thing
print stuff out see if you can find out
something that you're trying to do is
not doing what you think it is you know
are there some tools that I can look at
to help me of course the debugger is
good in this case you know we could we
could start looking at hey isn't there
command to find out what type something
is in Python yes this is called type but
here's the thing I makes me crazy
because I do it every time oh yeah no
here's what you here's what you need to
do right we start solving problems we
don't understand how often have you done
that today we are constantly solving
problems we don't understand and how
often do we make a better how often do
we make them worse and so don't start
with a solution unless you're using it
then just okay make it a new branch and
then go ahead but don't start with a
solution because you're gonna mess
yourself up aren't you and I have people
come to me all the time they just swear
swear python is broken because it's not
working and it should okay there's
something you're not understanding and
there's nothing wrong with that but
there's something you're not
understanding and your assumptions are
probably a big part of the reason you're
not understanding things you're assuming
things that aren't true do some
detective work sherlock let's figure out
what's going on let's get in there and
find out what's happening there's lots
of tools for that you got to start by
understanding the problem a lot of times
I'll turn off the computer I'll be like
yeah turn off that computer here's the
whiteboard marker when they move my
office they were going to take away my
whiteboard and my bookshelves and I said
you can have my computer
true it's your story and they were like
you're nuts okay we'll give you the
whiteboard because we you scare us a
little so what did happen here okay now
you can say it's easy to assume the plus
sign is broken dang it this thing
doesn't even know how to add that's a
normal assumption though isn't it how
stupid is this now that's not really the
problem those of us who are experienced
see we're feeling superior because we
already know how because we've already
felt like idiots long ago when we forgot
it or we're just kind of a little you
know it we've all made this one haven't
we the plus sign is not really the
problem what's really the problem
you know Python that said interactive
mode I love that right if I try to do
Python plus meetup what's it gonna say
Python meetup there we go
wait a minute wait a cotton-picking
minute you can't add Python and meetup
can you okay be careful here because you
know I'm about to slap you because
somebody wants to say well operator
overloading is a form of polymorphism
and it's actually concatenated rather
than adding because it's automatically
detecting that these are strings and not
integers yeah
slap you with a wet fish for that when
you're around beginners all right when
you're around beginners this is the
worst thing we can say because they're
like yet you just switched in a
serbo-croatian or something they felt
stupid before now they feel worse so yes
is it is all that stuff true yes it
isn't wonderful when you understand it
yup
but do you have to understand that the
first day no no no I think it's enough
to say hey it's the plus sign is so
smart that it does different things when
it sees text and when it sees numbers
and apparently it thinks that five and
three is text I wonder if that's the
problem
can I test that right and then we google
again is there a way to find out what
type of data something is is there yeah
is it type or type of I get JavaScript
and Python confused every time I always
guessed wrong the first one its type
okay so we can apparently add text yes
concatenation and wonderful things two
or three or text we look up a tool the
type function tells us what we want to
know okay now we add a new tool to our
toolbox you see what I'm saying now we
add a new tool to our toolbox and we say
cool I need a new algorithm piece
convert to integer go look it up figure
out what you have to do looks like we
have an old in a variable and int
variable and convert old variable to
integer store an int variable oh look
there's code for it
that's all fun isn't it now we have a
new tool and that's how we continue
growing is as we encounter a problem we
develop a new algorithmic tool to get
there does that make sense so this is
this is pretty kind of fun isn't it
it is really in the geeky way all right
I know now we can try again with a new
tool notice what I did I killed my code
I can't believe it took me hours to
write that now we did it it took you
about 30 seconds to write it it took you
hours to understand it and you
understood it wrong really hard to get
people to throw away code isn't it like
us right okay fine
put it in a subdirectory but start fresh
get again man I love get but start fresh
because if it was worth keeping it would
have worked and you didn't lose the
thought process you just got yourself in
a bad place so I'm gonna rewrite my
algorithm now and I'll tell you the
truth I wrote this wrong the first time
I put it in the wrong order but before I
wrote an e code I was like dude that's
in the wrong order it's not gonna work
you see this I'm thinking about
programming before I write code because
it's often easier to see the order of
things see I converted to earth
but now I look at that I'm like that
makes sense
I could do that on a whiteboard I can be
the computer and now we'll put some code
in will this work yeah we could prove it
I can run it but it works
there's branching there's four loops I
want to talk a little bit about while
loops though and then we'll be done
you're good with that I don't know how
long we're supposed to go but you know
it could be the next election cycle
before I'm done it's an endless loop
that's the problem yeah let's just skip
this one okay so you know for loops
people sometimes get mad
Python people when they see the way that
I teach for loops because I say that a
for loop has lots of parts it has a
century it has a start it has a finish
it has a change and you're like that is
such a C++ for loop what is the matter
with you and yeah and I teach for loops
in Python you can see my code for Iron
Range start finished change oh that is
so unpack yes it is yes it is because
sometimes I want to teach Python and
sometimes I want to teach programming
and when I'm teaching beginners I'll do
this if Python uses chicken or third
language we'll do it with iterators but
this traditional structure lines up
better with other languages but much
more important it's much better for
learning to debug properly because when
you have a loop what are the three
things you always think about in a loop
well four things really first is this
century what is this variable that
controls the whole thing right and then
what are three things about the century
you need to know sing-alongs people you
know this how does it start how's it
finish has it changed which seems so
simple right but how many loops have you
had that have gone terribly wrong what's
the most likely basic code structure to
go wrong a loop especially if you see a
boolean operator in that son-of-a-gun
death two boolean operators
yes yep
or the falseness there gave me that one
that was too easy
we're gonna come back to that thought
real quick anyway a while loop so what
are the four things you need to know
about a while loop
what's the century how's it start how's
it in how's it change but no that's not
true Andy the while loop has only one
parameter that's the problem with while
loops the while loop implies a lot that
it doesn't require and that's why a
while loops go wrong so often don't they
because if you're gonna make a while
loop you were also have a holy
obligation to it to think about what the
Sentry is even though the while it
doesn't require to you have to
initialize this entry before you got
there which means you have to plan ahead
which means why are you writing code you
should be doing algorithms and then
somewhere inside the loop we don't know
where you have to change this century
and you have to change it in a way that
guarantees that at one point you'll
trigger the condition oh yeah we need a
condition but you never forget that one
you will sometimes make a condition
that's impossible to to satisfy though
won't you marriage seminar or something
but no so these are the same things that
are required in a while loop and that's
why I teach them first in the for loop
because how easy is it to mess that up
now you don't do it all right here we go
here's the example basic password loop
leave out on this one right it exits
with a positive recite result if the
user chooses the right password but if
they get it wrong it launches misses so
if you get it wrong three times sorry
about your luck sending the missiles all
right we could all do this how you gonna
coat it okay really how are you gonna
cut it
all right we'll use a compound condition
right with a boolean now I love boolean
variables don't get me wrong it's
boolean operators that bug me because
here's why because what condition do we
need on this thing let's see tries is
greater than equal to 3 and guess is not
equal to correct yeah that's it or is it
because now guess is the negative and de
Morgan's law it's as a boolean variable
okay take a picture cuz it go away so
correct as in d pi tries to 0 keep going
is true well keep going you know what I
love about boolean variables there's
just a not not a lot that can go wrong
it's about the cleanest variable type
you got right I love boolean variables I
don't love boolean operators as much
unless I'm working on just boolean
variables with them but well keep going
if this thing is true and is it it
better be well I'll keep going it true
do whatever code I want yes I
deliberately did not do the format thing
because I don't want to freak out
beginners it's really cool but not today
now take a look if gas is equal to
correct then we'll say that's great
here's the treasure and then look at
this beautiful thing that's where that's
where the break statement goes doesn't
it now we should never write break
should we I know switch statements thank
you for not including those you know
yeah keep going it's false that means
the next time I evaluate this loop we're
out how clean is that and what do I
really mean by this line I don't want to
keep going like that it's gonna be much
easier to follow house if that rises I
didn't really do Elif Elif is like a
dwarf but it's taller and then the years
if tries is greater than or equal to 3
then we're gonna print hey too many
wrong tries launching the missiles once
again we're not directly exiting the
loop but we're telling it the next time
you evaluate I don't want to keep going
any more you know what's funny is I
no the last time I wrote a while loop
that didn't just say while keep going
because once you get used to this man
it's beautiful it is just beautiful
and I read a lot of games you know game
code gets messy doesn't it
no could gets Messier the game code
partially because we don't design for
maintenance in gaming you know it's
gonna be out of date and in a year so in
gaming you don't design it to be
maintained you designed to be fast and
so you're at some junk okay
eventually we'll teach all these things
at their time but not today you're good
with that yeah no let's just stop with
this
so why Python right I mean I've taken a
lot of time to tell you tonight that the
language doesn't matter yet it's a
Python group and I do love Python so if
the language doesn't matter why did we
choose Python well I'll show you okay
you recognize this right what language
are we in old school see man this is the
way God intended pointers everywhere no
strings those strings are for wusses all
right there's some seat and there's kind
of you know how the world is too simple
to really get the feel of a language
isn't it so I say really we need to do
hello user that is it ask the user's
name and then it does something with it
that's the smallest program I think we
can really get the sense of a flavor of
a language would you agree and would it
be possible for me to take that little
chart we just did and show you how to do
all those things in C absolutely
absolutely there C but don't worry
hey Buren how you doing they see all
these people in the open source world
they have the best names don't they
you know Vito and Bjorn and stuff like
that yeah I figured that's the only
reason I'm not at the top of the open
source world is my name is too obvious I
was gonna go with one of the sub-saharan
languages with clicking and stuff my
name is David Harris
either that or just switch they skip the
human language is all together go to
Dolphin I'm sorry
all right so C++ Wow
at this level C++ looks like a dream
doesn't it no more print different c++
must be easy yeah if you've done some
yeah if and def anyone yeah yep
ok C++ is pretty nice at this level but
it gets hard fast all right here's my
favorite right public static void main
string args have you ever tried to teach
Java to a beginner you've ever been to a
beginner Java class that I mean every
Java teacher in the world who has to
teach beginners and this was me that's
what they wanted in Nicaragua please
teach this in Java please wave a dead
chicken over your shoulder turn around
three times it's a ritual throw salt
type this line and they're like we do
not have a chicken nevermind I don't
really mean that it's just a ritual
because I don't want to teach you what a
static method is yet that doesn't make
sense if we haven't done objects and we
shouldn't be doing objects yet you're
just trying to make a variable so this
makes me crazy you know I love me some
Java
I do love Java and I love Java for more
advanced programmers because it doesn't
let you do some stupid things that we
like to do anyway right
dual inheritance now I looked at my kids
I think multiple inheritance is a good
idea there so there's Java yeah it makes
sense doesn't it could we again like all
these languages could I take that char
to make it work for Java sure I've done
it so why Python that's why if you want
to teach a beginner to program which of
these languages is easiest to translate
from the algorithm to code that actually
works that's what I love about Python
because since I don't care about the
language how about we pick one that gets
out of the way and gives them success
to succeed I want them to feel proud I
want them to fail because that's gonna
happen but I want them to overcome that
failure and so a language that helps us
do that that makes me happy makes me
happy and I like successful students and
here's the other thing they are gonna
want to make games fine we can do that
somebody's gonna want to write a
database sequel lights built-in good now
they all want to do - you eyes okay fine
TK yeah TK but hey it's built in what do
you want to do sure we can do it get it
out of your sister you wanna do web apps
I taught that tonight I showed them they
were still this is their first Python
class I showed them bottle because
there's no installation I don't want to
deal with it's don't like flask on the
yeah computer how cool is this
isn't this fun so that's really where I
am I love to teach beginners because I
love the process of learning and I
always learn far more than them so thank
you for your time I'll be around to
answer any questions you guys been
awesome a lot of fun
[Applause]